(glove snaps)
(phone rings)
- Thanks for calling Mahogany Books.
How can I help you?
- [Jason] For Mahogany Books
in Southeast Washington DC,
this is what business unusual looks like.
Orders taken by phone.
- Yes ma'am.
- [Jason] Books sanitized
before being hand-delivered
to customers parked out front.
- Oh, thank you so much.
- [Jason] Derrick and Ramunda Young
quit their full-time jobs years ago
to pursue their dream,
creating Mahogany Books,
a home for readers seeking literature
on the African American experience.
- The biggest premise was how do we make
black books accessible
no matter where you live.
I'm from Oklahoma, proud
to be from Oklahoma,
but I didn't have that type
of access to black books.
- [Jason] When they founded
Mahogany Books 13 years ago,
it was an online bookstore.
Nearly three years ago, they opened this,
their brick and mortar business.
The Youngs say that it quickly grew
to account for 75% of their revenue.
Then coronavirus hit.
- Everything had stopped and
we had to shut our doors.
It was a little scary
in the very beginning
because this was our bread and butter.
- [Jason] African American
small business owners
have been disproportionately
affected by the pandemic.
Because the Youngs had already
built their online business,
they didn't have to shut down entirely,
but nationwide, from February
to April of this year,
the number of active African American
small business owners dropped 41%
compared to 22% of all
active small business owners.
- We have to be wise.
We still have to look at funding
that comes in different areas
because now, with doors closed,
less traffic is coming in our space.
- [Jason] When the Federal
Paycheck Protection Program,
or PPP, passed as part of
the CARES Act in late March.
- The motion is adopted.
(politicians cheer)
(gavel pounds)
- [Jason] The Youngs
applied to the program
through their bank.
- Before I was able to figure it out,
the first allotment of
money had already run out.
It takes a little bit more
for, I think, genuinely small businesses
to figure out how to
navigate some of these things
because that's not necessarily
what our wheelhouse is.
- [Jason] The Youngs experienced this
like many other African
American small businesses
trying to take advantage of PPP.
- Knowing the history
of financial exclusion
means that we have a
program that was already
not gonna work to the best advantage
of business owned by people of color.
- Ashley Harrington is a policy expert
at the Center for Responsible Lending,
a non-profit consumer advocacy group.
So these programs go through the SBA,
the Small Business Administration.
- They go through the SBA,
but the intermediary is
a financial institution.
- Has this posed challenges
to African American businesses
more so than business owners at large?
- It absolutely has, right.
So any time we have a program
that relies so heavily
on traditional financial institutions,
we're automatically gonna have a problem
for businesses owned by people of color,
particularly businesses
owned by black people,
to get access to the funds
because they have a different
type of relationship
with major financial institutions
than other communities.
They have typically not been served well
by the financial mainstream.
- [Jason] The SBA says it
and the Treasury Department
value all lenders and are
actively engaged in outreach
to Community Development
Financial Institutions
and Minority Depository Institutions.
"CDFIs and MDIs," it says,
"have traditionally excelled
"in providing financial assistance
"to minority communities and
underserved populations."
The Youngs say that, when
they launched their business,
they didn't rely on the banking system.
- We didn't go to banks
and get approved for loans.
We had to bootstrap it ourselves
and pull out of our 401ks that we had
when we were working and go to friends.
- [Jason] So when the
Youngs didn't hear back
about their PPP application,
and they still haven't,
it's been weeks, they embraced the same
entrepreneurial spirit that they had
when they first opened their business.
They moved in-person author
talks to virtual sessions.
- To have a conversation
about where black America is.
- [Jason] They participated
in DC's curbside pickup
pilot program.
And they created book bundles
for parents homeschooling.
And now, following the
killing of George Floyd,
the Youngs say there's
been a growing demand
for their books.
They say they've seen a 400% increase
in online sales over the previous year.
Since closing their store to customers,
the Youngs say revenue
has dropped only 10%.
- Even though online has
been rockin' and rollin',
we don't know how long this new space,
this new era's gonna be here, right.
So even though today it's great,
I'm assuming that, after a while,
the online will kind of drop off,
and so that's what we're looking at
with grants and different
funding in that way.
(paper rustles)
- [Jason] To help bridge the gap
and support their three
part-time employees,
they also applied for and were granted
an Economic Injury Disaster Loan, or EIDL,
through the Small Business Administration.
EIDLs of up to $10,000 were
designed, the SBA says,
"to provide economic relief to businesses
"that are currently experiencing
"a temporary loss of revenue."
They don't have to be repaid.
- So we can have it shipped
out with the other book.
No, you're valid.
- [Jason] They know part of
their value to the community
is in their curation.
- Our logo is our daughter reading a book.
- [Jason] And helping parents
pass on their heritage
to their children.
- Having the online space be there
has been the lifesaver for us
because people can still shop,
people can still get the
resources they need at home
as they're homeschooling their kids,
especially if they're looking
at culturally-sensitive
and culturally-aware books and resources.
They now have a spot that
they can still do that
no matter where they live.
- Experts say the net effect
of black-owned small businesses
facing disproportionate challenges
could persist well beyond
the COVID pandemic.
So could what we've been discussing today
have an impact on the
wealth disparity in America?
- Absolutely.
The important thing to remember
is that business ownership
had an incredible impact
on wealth creation, right.
Business owners of color
were more likely to have
a lot more wealth than people of color
who don't own businesses.
So business ownership
is definitely one way
to help people of color build wealth
and get on the track to
closing the wealth gap.
And so when we have a situation like this
where they can't get access
to a critical lifeline
that will help them stay
afloat and stay open,
they are definitely losing wealth
and that has a ripple effect
in their entire community.
- [Jason] The Youngs may be doing better
than other minority businesses
in their community right now,
perhaps because they're
able to offer something
of intangible value, escape and knowledge
at a time of immense hardship.
- So the total is $18.02.
Thank you for supporting us as well.
It means a lot, yeah.
(soft music)